the boxing legend lennox lewis won
olympic gold before a master class in
professional ranks and became britain's
only undisputed heavyweight champion of
the world one of the best to ever done a
pair of gloves but he's not undefeated
in the boardroom
dennis couldn't win without me as often
as he does anyone knew as much he knows
that i think you'd agree with that i
could probably do do you agree with that
yes i do
i wouldn't have answered it that way
linux i would have said absolutely who
the hell do you think you are i'd never
admit that
he's a good asset to the team
i'm the main asset lennox you're
fantastic but you fired it
a terrible moment watching the world
heavyweight champion getting knocked out
by me
uh
lennox great to see you mate i did the
bruises
you still feel those bruises of the big
old morgan ko
no i think uh i think i don't know what
happened i think he paid him some money
[Laughter]
can you believe he went on to be
president of the united states and is
now like the most famous divisive guy on
the planet
yeah he's uh
incredible
in fact just before we came on air
tonight alex the uh elon musk who's just
bought twitter said this
it was not correct
to
ban donald trump i think that was that
was a mistake her bands just
fundamentally undermine trust in twitter
as
a a
town square uh where um everyone can
uh voice their opinion so that was the
breaking news alex that uh elon musk
who's now got twitter of course he's
bought it he wants trump back on twitter
do you think that's a good thing
well you know um
i think he thinks it's a good thing so
you know he's a he's a pretty he's
pretty smart man
let's turn to why i wanted you on the
show alex i i've had a sneaking feeling
that society's gone all week in the last
couple of decades that this kind of new
mentality of celebrating victimhood
people quitting left right and center
being called heroes
in the sporting arena in real life none
of it feels right to me do you get that
sense as well and what do you think
about it
you know there's definitely a a turn a
switch uh a difference of opinion
and you know people want to do it
different ways and uh you know they're
getting an opportunity to teach you
but do you think that society should
toughen up do you think that we need to
go back to perhaps what it was like when
you were young
when you you know you weren't allowed to
be self-pitying you had to crack on
yeah i i believe that you know right now
people
um even when it comes to fighting look
at when it comes to fighting people run
for weapons they should fist fight like
fight do it like the old times
and then as far as the boxing training
nowadays a lot of people stay at home go
to camp you know
isolate yourself focus dedicate
what do you make of tyson fury i would
love to see you guys fight both at your
peak who would you think would have won
oh i refuse to answer easy questions
well mate you are talking to any bloke
who's knocked you out apart from two
other guys that you wouldn't be so i'm
undefeated against you seriously would
you do you think you'd have beaten tyson
tyson fury listen tyson fury is a great
champion you know he moves well he's
elusive and he punches hard got a great
job great uppercut now and uh all he has
to do is clean up the division like i
did and then beat the next generation
well yeah you're slightly ducking the
question though come on if it was you
two in the ring who's gonna win at your
best and you'll you you can't put you
can't put two cronk fighters against
each other you know that's not that's
that's naughty
i also wanted to ask you because you
knocked out the other tyson mike tyson
and he just today got announced will not
face any charges after giving a
passenger on a plane a slap for annoying
him what did you make of that do you get
that kind of hassle
um
no you know
i think he dealt with it wrong obviously
when you poke the beer uh
you know he's gonna he's gonna react i
would have just turned around and
slapped him and said
that's what he did
that's
wasn't
it
he did you told me when we did the
apprentice together you told me that at
the peak of your world heavyweight
champion powers you go into nightclubs
and the biggest guy would come up to you
and try it on and i said to you well
what would happen and he went dude what
do you think happened i was the world
heavyweight champion of the world
yeah plus you know mentally mentally i i
play the whole thing in my head with of
course me winning of course of course
and one thing i would say we play 40 we
play 40 games of chess doing the
apprentice filming and you beat me 39
times out of 40. i still remember the
one i won but you were very good at
chess
yeah people won't remem won't believe
that you actually counted every time we
played i did i did and i don't forget
the fact that every time you were about
to check mate me you stood up and walked
around the board rubbing your hands in
glee you were a very annoying person to
play chess with
thank you that's a compliment
it's always great to catch up with you
mate thanks for coming on the show thank
you stay uncensored i love you the way
you are and i'm sorry again for knocking
you out but sometimes you just meet a
superior guy in life it's just the way
it is okay good to talk to you don't
worry i'll get you next time bless
all the best champ